oh boy
this is a mistake this is a huge mistake
okay
hi folks huh
so i'm gonna give it a few minutes uh
before i actually start
this up because i want to be sure that
everyone who is interested
in actually uh watching this thing
simultaneous with simultaneously with me
because
they feel like suffering uh is geared up
to do that
uh for the record if you're not uh
already aware the
film is available for streaming on
disney plus
and actually you know what i'm going to
adjust the lighting it's the first time
i've done it
this way that's coming in a little
bright hang on
one second
so if we go with that how do i look
yeah that'll do this is not citizen kane
how's tricks well they're okay at the
moment they're about to go very very
badly
i recommend you um have
water close to hand for this
thank you carolyn uh
was watching 12 monkeys for the first
time but i guess i could watch you
suffer through a bad movie instead
oh boy 12 monkeys i haven't
seen i haven't re-watched that one in a
while although i'm probably going to end
up using footage from it uh
for a video that's going up later this
month
so malt water go
sing single malt or uh
uh that cord is right down my cleavage
okay so yeah i'll give it i'll give it
just a couple minutes
uh you're not drinking so i can oh great
so now i have to drink for two
wonderful
uh finally watched four lions i get what
you mean by freaking you out
yeah yeah i don't i don't know how to
explain it
to anyone who hasn't seen it but oh that
movie
oh man like and like i i
praised that what it managed to do but
drinking liquid death water
hey whatever gets you through
okay so guess i'll give it
i'll give it another two minutes we'll
start at five past
first time committing uh to this all the
way through looking forward
to it i think well i mean you know it's
better with friends
could be worse you could be watching
cuties i have no way like here's the
thing
i don't even really want to wade into
the
into the waters of that thing from what
i understand
the the backlash on it is
largely unfounded or stems from a
fundamental misunderstanding of what the
film is actually doing but there's still
areas of concern i just don't want to
get there will you be able to hear the
audio
no randomness unfortunately not that's
why i have the headphones if
if i did it in a way where the audio
from the film could be heard by you
this would get flagged by bots and the
stream would get shut down
so um unfortunately if you don't have
your own means to queue up the movie
you're just gonna have to go by how i
react so
like th this is an experiment uh i've
never done something like this on a live
stream and i don't know how well it's
gonna work i don't know how entertaining
it's going to be
i don't know if the slide should be
worth it but we won't know until we try
so that's that's what we're doing uh
all right give it one more minute
don't worry we we won't pay you to watch
cuties because
not even you deserve to sit through that
train wreck
thank you i i excuse me i appreciate
that
uh
thank you for that carowind well caught
i hope it works cause i have some movies
uh to recommend oh dear
uh last thing uh did you get my email
with the link to my audio series just
curious i did
i haven't had the time to listen to it
but i did
i did get that so thank you um
all right 705 so i guess here we go so
anyone who also has this
cued up why do i hate the shiny honestly
i feel like i need to devote a video to
that one of these days but
short answer it's not scary and the
characters aren't interesting
like i understand it's meticulously made
but i don't care because i'm not engaged
okay so here we go
i'm hitting the play button in five
four three two
one i've been told it's
it's weird that i count down that way
as opposed to going the other way i
don't know is that weird or is it just
me
all right we gotta turn this up a little
so
i can hear it better and hear it over my
blabbing because i will be talking
how much for you to watch the last jedi
again
same as it is to commission to watch to
get me to watch anything else
so head on over to the patreon see if
there's an open slot
uh
you've seen other people do it that way
okay
oh the marvel logo oh that must have
hurt them so much that they had to put
their logo on this
oh no oh
oh no don't tell me we're starting with
one of the characters in high school
oh no it's not even high school it's
like middle school oh
no oh this is not a good start
you were watching ghostbusters you
decided to watch this with me why
just to see me suffer oh look homer
simpson's the
the teacher
oh wow look at the super intelligent
child who look
um
oh yes of course i i've already built it
look
here's the here's what drives me crazy
about this as a trope
like i'll believe that kids can have the
processing power at a young age but like
you you have not been alive enough to
absorb all the information
you need to know 10 000 hours that's how
long you have to put into something to
be an expert
i highlighted the f in the fox a little
bit like they did with x and the x-men
movies oh god i didn't even notice that
rowan you're
uh you shouldn't suffer alone
i appreciate that uh
hey he does a bunch of incoherent
doodles in his notebook that means he's
smart
or a serial killer
if you hadn't guessed already i'm gonna
snark the crap out of this and probably
more than it actually deserves but uh
that
that's the tone i'm setting that is the
uh the level of discourse
that i shall be maintaining this evening
for your viewing pleasure
don't tell my manager i'm watching you
at work
lips are sealed
oh you know they're top because they
listen to hip hop
oh boy
oh come on really
oh they're gonna do that to clobbering
time
come on
because we can't have ben
grimm just be a tough guy who's good at
what he does he's got to be somebody
with trauma
and it's because dark equals depth
somehow
[Music]
okay so he's building a teleporter
with spare parts from cars
a power come a power com
you got to go down to tashi station for
the power converters read
what the flipping hell
i'm gonna need something stronger than
booze i don't partake of things
stronger than booze i partake of booze
of various strengths
uh but i don't partake of things
stronger than booze
ff series has been so unfortunate for
attempts and four failures
and honestly the roger corman one's
probably the most entertaining
there was a menorah on the shelf so they
remember grim was jewish okay
that's something that's a good catch
that's nice yeah i'm hydrated
as well that's the only way i can get
through this
and look i'm like i'm
i'm giving crap to this whole genius
child thing but like
it it's a trope and it's
there's nothing inherently wrong with it
i just
i don't like it i've never really liked
it
even as a kid when it was like a big
thing in the 80s
i didn't like it all that much
um
a shot for every oh no or will that be
dangerous that'll probably be dangerous
especially considering that as the
evening wears on
uh i sure as heck wouldn't keep track of
how often i say things like that
the two mid-2000 films are flawed some
redeeming elements
they are like the the cast dynamics
pretty good
in those but it's
there's a lot of problems
what do you think they should do with
the new ones in the mcu um i actually
like
movie bob's idea of having the fantastic
four
b time travelers from the 60s
um
disney's gonna remake fantastic four
well yeah eventually of course they will
is this the explorers remake it might as
well be
so far and let me guess
the whole oh no it didn't reach the
whole city oh
okay didn't quite hit that cliche
the negative zone
awesome i made weed
oh you know what excuse me for a second
here
yeah that's better
we're up to high school how the hell
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute the same teacher
is coming to hassle him seven years
later when he's in high school
i did no
that would not be the same damn teacher
fantastic 420.
uh so wait he's it's like a science fair
for high school and
like grade school they're in the same
what
is that what they're doing to cover for
the fact that the same teacher is there
like i don't
i oh miles miles teller that was his
name
liz asked me uh before like who was in
this and i could not remember his name
boom yep there we go
i wouldn't mind the ability to pour a
lot of spare parts
it uh if the tone allowed for that kind
of silliness yeah they are going for a
more serious tone it's
it yeah that doesn't jibe
brad bird i i
am not as in love with brad bird as a
lot of people are
like his best movie hands down was the
iron giant i
oh now wait a minute
let me guess
me major scientific minds
are scouting out
science fairs not not even college like
level like high school science fairs
that also have freaking grade school
kids in them
actual high level scientists are
scouting them out trying to find
somebody who'd
[Music]
oh
oh my god keep an eye on zeus here
throughout the film yeah i heard about
that
the uh there's like the straw wig
i love that adam you're a genius read
i'm a what
i'm from this organization you've never
heard of come into my unmarked van
[Music]
so i guess this is their version of the
baxter building
yeah that's vaguely interesting it's
like an older style building for the
first
20 floors or so and then it's like
clearly been built on top of
yeah it's actually kind of into
oh they wear lab coats that's how you
know it's real science
it's not real science if you don't have
a lab coat on
that's a fact
um
can you impersonate the thing
well all you have to do is like get the
growl in your voice and go
it's clubber in time some version of
that
i can't quite get the resonance though
my voice doesn't go that deep
like it goes reasonably deep i can get
it down there a bit
but you know whatever
been shorter than him who cares he's
gonna be a rock monster anyway
how does the thing pee i think the more
important question is
what does the thing be
is it a stream of pebbles are his
internal organs
rock can his liver process anything
who knows
the thing doesn't wear pants in this oh
that's right in this movie he doesn't
does he
oh
[Music]
that means he lost his junk
i mean granted good luck finding someone
well
outside of certain kinks circles who was
going to go for it but
still that's sad jamie bell and kate
mara are married now
really i was unaware
because you know i don't care
i don't mean like it okay it's fine to
tell me but like i don't care about
who's married to who
the thing has no dick not necessarily it
could be a reptile
okay so like if the rocks are a form of
scales then yes that means it's
he's he's tucked inside uh you've kind
of got the um
shape of water thing going the
sort of deal
you can tell she's smart because she's
describing music
in mathematical terms that means smart
huh
joaquin phoenix name just kid river and
i'm touched oh
that is sweet
that's that's deep
don't mock me can you impersonate
am i is it the fact that i'm hydrating
that you're asking me for impersonations
uh
i really do like that at that actor
who's playing
uh sue's dad but uh okay beetlejuice
it's showtime that's that's it like i
if i didn't have this playing in my ears
i could like think of other lines from
it but like
too much input
i'm i'm sorry sir i'm sorry franklin
you're an idiot if victor von doom
has previously had a falling out with
you and firebombed your servers
and you know is also named victor von
doom
you don't need him on your team
now i'm uh i'm siding with the suits on
this one
looking glass huh
am i am i like
you you went over my head
and i instantly can't take this
seriously
here's the thing about the name victor
von doom
it really only works
if he is a dictator of latvia and
it is presumed to be the name he gave
himself
if you're gonna tell me somebody is just
named victor von doom
you don't get to do this tone you don't
get to do this dark serious tone it does
not freaking work
tim blake nelson is looking glass in
watchmen oh yes okay yes he is
i i didn't register that that was his
nickname that you were linking okay
i got i'm with you now with you now
yeah i'll get some tea might put whiskey
in it i yeah
whatever gets you through
okay see now you're feeding me lines
just uh
all right fine fine
ah well i attended juilliard i'm a
graduate of the howard business school i
traveled quite extensively i lived
through the black plague and i had a
pretty good time during that i've seen
the exorcist about 157 times
and it keeps getting funnier every
single time i see it
not to mention the fact that you're
talking to a dead guy so what do you
think
you think of qualified
there you go
victor wasn't called doom originally it
was a re-shoot yeah i heard about that
nice wig
you've not got back to me about an
interview um
shoot me another email because i lose
track of things
like legitimately i i will lose track of
things
and if i don't respond to something
right away it will
go down in the feed and i will lose
track of it that is the thing that
happens
if i had the money for a personal
assistant i would hire one in a
heartbeat
to help me manage all this stuff but uh
shoot me another email counseling geeks
gmail.com on that i'm sorry
toby kevin was victor von doom a much
better villain
as a monkey and dawn of the planet of
the apes yeah like
dawn on the planet of the apes was about
the only thing that made me think oh
maybe he is an okay actor
you should play beetlejuice and broadway
touring company
i i i don't have the uh the credentials
to uh
to get to tour on stage
could they decide on what his accent is
i've heard like three different things
in two sentences
you don't have a personal assistant here
oh carowind you are an immense help and
actually you
like legitimately caroline helps me out
a lot and draws me reminders for stuff
but i mean like
i mean like to the point i honestly need
a personal
assistant on the level that i would have
to pay someone to
like manage my calendar and be frontline
email
or you know i i wouldn't ask that of you
but you are
you are indispensable help
okay dude pick an
accent my god
on the scale of one to ten how smart was
it of me to ditch ghostbusters
and watch fan four stick
zero
love kristoff vols to play victor in the
mcu that'd be solid
there are no greater minds than the
teen to 20 somethings in this room
excuse me
blah blah blah blah blah doctor in
distress would have been shorter just
saying
uh ben i i will i'll do it
depending on how hydrated i am by the
time i finish this maybe i'll do it
right after this movie who the heck
knows
i was just teasy bear i know carowind
and you tease me wonderfully
trouble with watching this again is i
now doubt chronicle was any good
yeah yeah like here's
you know what the thought occurred to me
a little bit earlier that
now it it does really seem like david
ayer is going to try and gear up
to lead a campaign for the air cut of
suicide squad the way snyder did for the
sniders cut of
justice league like the logical end
point of this is people demanding that
they release the tranq
cut oh
i mean so johnny's a street racer that
that tracks about as well as anything
else
uh dude you are not gonna recover from a
from a lead like that
courtesy isn't this because movie
[Music]
what's worse this is suicide squad too
early to call
ask me at the end
ah reckless endangerment love it
you're gonna overheat the engine boom
there it goes dude like do you not know
how cars work
you freaking idiot yes
uh miles teller went from oscar nominee
whiplash to this movie
it's one of the biggest steps down in
cinema history in his defense
like there were plenty of great
actors taking up superhero movies
i i can't blame him for rolling the dice
i'm pretty sure there wasn't a script at
the time he signed on
i want the god cut of life i see it
depends on which god if we're talking
old testament god i think we might
actually be living that already
what made chronicle great was decent
script written by a monster
and dane dehan carrying the film i
actually thought dan dahm was one of the
weaker
of the main three in that maybe that's
me
i think i think it's look his look is
just so
you can't you can't get anything other
than like oh you're you're creepy
off him so like
what's your vocal range i'm a baritone
um what is it with the fixation on the
live stream i'm not wearing a
lab coat
i'm a big boy i don't wear lab coat they
have lab coats
now here's the rule of threes are we
gonna have a third bad
observation about lab coats
josh trang has since done a film with
tom hardy as uh as a dimension suffering
ala capone who craps himself
oh that was him wasn't it
okay that line was actually good
that that was a decent line about the
not taking orders volatility you're
funny oh good that's a relief
funny's good
uh
miles teller still had a line uh as a
legion to come oh god i forgot he was in
that series i haven't seen any of those
and i won't unless you pay me
uh oh it's the
it's the learning montage put that
science work
look through microscopes
stand in front of blinky computer lights
scribble
scribble harder yes
science drink
coffee use
tools create
helmets it's the
world of the future as they bond over
chinese
uh phillip class did half the score for
this by the way
who did the other half just trying to
since in the studio messed with his
original cover component i'm not kidding
so like that's his excuse for everything
now
uh it's the next live stream on election
night oh
god oh it is isn't it
i'm definitely gonna be drinking man uh
you can only choose beetle juice or the
lost boys oh
that's the oh that's not fair
beetlejuice
let's speed through the build on this
thing there we go
we have built it with science
life's not fair is it you see i
i will never be queen
i miss the lost boys i i am sorry about
that caroline
ah you can tell they're committed
because they sleep at their desks
and you can tell they're bonding because
they joke around and flick each other's
ears
grim yep sums it up yeah yeah
oddly uh poetic that bit
always be clean to us oh thank you
ah let's see
okay so established as adopted
because the world friggin freaked out
because they were a multi-racial family
oh no
oh oh oh cue the oh the jealous
reflection
oh whoever would have thought that a guy
named von
doom would be a problem
and what why do they gotta pull the
victor's crushing on
sue thing the 2000s ones did that too
it didn't work then oh
if not man before christmas ever makes
it to broadway you should play jack
skellington
uh
only dust and
a plaque that reads hilarize poor
old jack
i i may have had that uh
projection of myself at some point
uh
do you still watch chronicle i haven't
been able to since max landis's
allegations came out despite my love for
the film i only ever saw it the once
it was it was never on my list of repeat
viewing anyways
um so
i saw the once and it was good it was
fine
especially for low budget
swooning on thank you
more glaring from von doom okay so i'm
assuming tim blake nelson is somehow
a dick because they like shared uh
they like shared up ooh we're doing evil
glance
monkey in space
you kind of do look like jonathan groff
really
i think i've got a uh a couple of cup
sizes on him
can't keep singing uh tim blake nelson
still needs to return as the leader in
the mcu
she hulk series i'll bet i would love
that i'm not expecting it
that would be awesome though that would
be fantastic
video acquisition no signal oh you mean
there's no wi-fi in the negative zone
oh no signal established i guess i guess
they just needed to um
to steal it from the neighbor
i attempted to try the first few seasons
of dexter but then
just stop right there good idea um i
mean i would personally say stop at
season two because i think it's the best
one
most people tell you go to season four
uh toby please remember my one episode
of black mirror cable
yeah yeah
now i'm curious because that is a very
recent planet of the apes
looking monkey did toby kevin play that
too
uh stephanie beatrice is she hulk
i'd be down for that i mean because
apparently it's not gonna be tatiana
muslany which was the rumor
uh which series finale was worse dexter
game of thrones
dexter dexter was still worse because
game of thrones gave an ending that they
hadn't properly earned but you could see
where maybe
how they could have dexter's ending just
doesn't
there's nothing they could have done to
make the decisions made in that ending
work
there are things that could have been
they would have had to have been done
seasons ago
but there are things you could have done
in game of thrones to make those endings
actually work
wait that was just a rumor i thought it
was confirmed no no it got uh it got
shot down last week
given the fact that it wasn't shot down
sooner i suspect she was probably
actually in talks
for the part but then didn't sign
wait wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
these kids thought they were going to
travel through this
yes because the nerds who design jet
planes then get to personally fly them
as opposed to qualified fighter pipe
why would you think they'd send you
through this dimensional thing and then
get pissed when it turns out
that they want to send astronauts who
have gone into space cause that's the
closest thing to what you'd be asking
them to do now
you freak ah i mean one thing was just
victor
because he's a dick but like reed's all
like oh
i thought it was gonna go why why would
you think that
will you do a top 10 worst series finale
i doubt i ever will
just because i don't watch enough tv to
feel like i can speak definitively
and i think to truly appreciate a bad
serious finale you need to have stuck
with the show you can't just watch the
finale in isolation
because what's bad usually has to do
with how it betrays what came before
so i i would have to look into a bunch
of bad season
series finales and then like watch the
whole show leading up to appreciate how
bad it was and i don't have the time
to commit to that
yo mama jokes bonding
dexter's series finale was
uh the same week as breaking bads so not
only
is it awful it's also contrasting one of
the best finales ever
i didn't even get into breaking bad
until after i had finished
did ed harris think he was gonna go he
was gonna be on apollo 13 no
exactly
why would you ever make a list on the
movies that you hate but
would you ever make a list on the movies
that you hate but everyone else loves
uh maybe i'm not sure there are
that many on it the shining is probably
top of that particular list
i'd like i'd have to stop and really
think about what else i'd put on there
they thought they were going to go
because the script says so oh yes
you're right ben sorry silly of me
turn on the lights guys yeah seriously
just gonna drink in the dark
that's my job
uh because reed's an idiot well yes
demonstrably so
what what
so you're just gonna call your friend
from grade school
and say hey come to another dimension
with me
what what
oh this is some contrived nons this is
next level contrivance this oh
wow and this is this is this is
character based contrivance this is like
characters being
utter idiots just because it's what
moves the plot along
and gets the mandatory crap done like
ben has to be there but because there's
no reason for him to be there
he's just going to call him up and say
come with me to another dimension
you should do a tick tock video of you
dancing to hips don't lie by shakira
no no i really shouldn't i can't do that
much with my hips
you should you would put dumb and dumber
on that list oh god
do peop
do people still think dumb and dumber's
a good movie
i had hoped that like time had caught up
with me
and everyone understood that it was crap
and
always was like is that not an accepted
fact yet
have i deluded myself to thinking that
it was accepted truth
nearly an hour into a 99 minute film
they still don't have their powers
they don't have their powers they don't
have much in the way of motivation
they're all
idiots this is fun
and at what
how the hell was this thing designed in
such a way that they could
set it up to activate with them inside
and not need anybody else oh sorry i get
so never mind sue's not going so how
does she end up with powers if she's not
going
oh no wait no wait she's not activating
it she's just
become aware that they're doing it so
okay
back to my original question how would
they why would they design
something that can be that could be set
up to go
just by this small people and like no
one has to actively man it
they don't create a space shuttle that
can be launched by
only the pilots it's too easy to
freaking steal
oh
oh not in the world where people still
like ace ventura when nature calls
well youth are wrong
you should know that you can't wait for
people to realize that certain things
are terrible and bad on an unrelated
note looking forward to the election
would you rather be tied to a chair
gagged and forced to watch the shining
or dumb and dumber dumb and dumber
because it'd be over
faster that's the one mercy it's shorter
calm down dusk bunny it's just
for fun question mark
i made it i am von doom
wow dirt
thrilling
this planet looks boring and pointless
yeah i bet
it's uh very dark and generic
and now instagram jokes
i think you should come over and see how
we just caused a glowing crack in the
earth
let's go let's go hunt it down
and we're here with no return protocols
and no one knows we're here
and no one can pull us back if something
goes wrong
ah look by the stupid idiotic
measure that you've set forth for
yourselves you guys are going down in
the history books as the first people to
do this you've accomplished that just by
showing up
why must you now be further stupid
it wouldn't bother me so much except the
movie is so insistent that they're super
smart like for real
maybe that's maybe that's why uh they
had homer simpson
because all these characters have an
internal monologue going i am so smart
i am so smart smrt i mean smarty
how many times have you watched hamilton
on disney plus three
i really like the actor who played doom
of the 2000 movies
or do you think they went wrong with him
not read the comics
[Music]
he was fine but he wasn't victor von
doom he was a perfectly serviceable
run-of-the-mill
baddie but
she that
that that character that he played was
not victor von doom
in that movie that uh
that's the reality do you do push-ups no
[Music]
i drink water
ugh
yes reach down and touch the weird
electric greens
did this come out before or after
prometheus where everyone complained how
these scientists were stupid and like
just poked at the alien goo
i think this was that i think this came
out after and long enough actor that
they would have known all the
complaints people had about freaking
prometheus
and that going on and they just let's
just do it
because it's a comic book movie so who
cares
stop running and and just let the
geysers of green gatorade kill you
you're all too stupid to live
[Music]
huh the version of douma robot chicken
has a pretty faithful origin to the
comic version putting the mel-esque
metal mask on when it was still molten
hop like that was one of the stupidest
things that doom did
so
um although i always like jack kirby's
take
on on his scarring
like this isn't canon um but jack kirby
who was the co-creator of doom and the
original artist
his take was always that victor von
doom's scar
was just one scar across his face but
because he was
so single-mindedly pursuing perfection
that was unacceptable so
on with the mask or at least that's all
he had prior to putting that on
uh what are your thoughts on napoleon
dynamite i haven't rewatched it a long
time i did
i did used to like it
tina you fat lard come get some dinner
can you do the pennywise smile i don't
know i've never tried
i am
i don't know if that was it
so wait she has to manually override the
re-entry
so how the hell were you going to get
back if you need her to put
oh you you're all dumb you're
i i deem you all too stupid oh now
you're on fire
and you have rocks in your pod
and you just get blasted with energy so
i guess you'll
end so now you're transparent
yeah because that's all
logical oh this time he blacked out the
the city blacked out the city in
manhattan proper
good job reed there you go you're moving
up in the world
i assembled a rorschach costume before i
read the book and realized what he was
i've since turned it into a spider-man
noir costume for halloween that is a
much better call
uh any book recommendations yeah
anything by douglas adams
would you rather be a vampire wearable
vampire
you get you got to have some degree of
control
excuse me
what did you miss um lousy movie uh
what are we about halfway through this
thing
yeah about
power out new york never seen that in a
superhero movie before i know right so
original
i have a modulator trapped in my throat
please help
[Music]
oh no i needed that
oh he could join the nba now
watch sin city for the first time that's
a decent movie it needs to be re-edited
so that it's not three sections and they
all climax at the same time and you like
intercut between them
that's my big complaint with that uh
as next joker confirmed
yes now let's now let's make it body
horror style
because that fits
a movie where a character is named von
doom
uh if you really think about the real
hero of hamilton is eliza
arguably it's well it's debatable who
the
whether anyone is the quote-unquote hero
because i mean hamilton is
a very flawed person which the show
presents
your voice sounds rather hoarse when you
laugh that's concerning is it
i mean if i if i really like go with a
laugh i'll wear myself out of it that's
this is kind of a thing that happens
i don't smoke or anything if that's your
concern
that's that blender guns and roses
neither
i suppose led zeppelin by default
because there's like two songs of theirs
that i like
she's invisible
do you remember badger from firefly the
actor played a similar character in
supernatural i thought
he would have made a great penguin
my partner liz is has gotten into
supernatural she loves
crowley he is her favorite by far
do you watch big mouth nope
i'll give them this the uh the visual
effect on the
on the human torch isn't that bad
boom
turns 15 tomorrow that's another movie
that like i liked but i've only seen the
ones
and didn't feel the need to watch again
i think partly because i liked uh
the nice guys better i'd rewatch that
first
[Music]
god i feel really bad for the actor
please that you can tell he's acting
across from nothing she's like oh he's
like he's emoting like hell but he has
no idea what he's looking at so it
doesn't work
what are your thoughts on carrie from
1976 pretty good movie
of its time but pretty decent it ain't
subtle i'll
give you tell you that
have you seen vivarium came out earlier
this year was weird as hell
watch it if you want to see jesse
eisenberg take a 40 foot
deep hole no not really oh wow oh hey
oh geez this effect is terrible
oh no no
right after i said the fire effects are
kind of okay oh the stretch effects are
so
bad oh
whoa oh
oh we got rubber stretchy sounds
that's awesome crowley's my favorite too
and lucifer before it became a walking
meeting did you recognize him and doctor
who
yes i've told i've told liz that he
shows up in doctor who
with an american accent no less
what what what happened to me you've got
no dick anymore dude that's what
happened
here comes the rock biter
uh do you watch bob burgers not
currently
i i've seen it
so wait are his legs still strapped in
and he's like just stretched his way
through the entire
ventilation shaft is that what is going
on here
the oriental theater here in milwaukee
holds the record for longest run of
midnight screens for the rocky horror
picture show
oh really
i thought it was like a theater in in
italy somewhere that had the longest
running
government bad
do you ever find yourself singing along
with the hamilton soundtrack um
not a ton but that's mostly because it's
been coming up uh
like on my playlist when i go running
and i can't sing and run
do you read a recommendation earlier
anything written by secretary pratchett
before the alzheimer's
can somebody turn on a freaking light
we've already seen him
why are you hiding him i know why
because the cgi in every single frame
costs money as opposed to doing at least
partially
practically so all you would have had to
do was point a
freaking camera at it wouldn't cost you
any more after you've already built the
damn thing
why is this up why is this like a big
reveal we've already
seen you
oh god the lip movement on that is
terrible one year
one year later one year
really
so we're just going to jump to a year
later where he has been
a co not even a coach he can't be covert
he's been a special op for the military
what
what wow
what are your thoughts on the walking
dead i only ever watched the first
season
i didn't think it was bad i'm just like
i'm not getting anything new out of this
or possibly they removed his junk for
further steady
oh god the wig holy god
wow that wig
oh do you think it'd be likely for the
tv salmon to have cameos from a zero
failing crowley i would
say very unlikely because the rights are
held by completely different companies
and now the second act one starts they
hit all the same introductory beats
oh boy quinn you seem to have it uh have
it on lockdown
it sure feels like you're going through
this movie yeah fair
there's a clip in the trailer of the
thing jumping off a helicopter onto a
plane which was cut
i remember that clip
wonder how much money was spent on that
thing that was never used
so we're not gonna watch them learn how
to use these powers even we just jump to
a year later and oh they know how to
control them now
[Music]
boy what are your thoughts on zombieland
one and two i enjoyed them
i enjoyed both of them
i i actually really liked the um
the valley girl character and the second
one
i have a feeling this is the reason for
disney being able to buy fox
well no disney bought fox because fox
internally realized that they were
losing ground in everything other than
their
news division and and they had the
choice to either sell it while it's
still
valuable or just wait for it to lose
value
continually over time like business-wise
they made the sound choice
how did they do lose first cameo in
crisis on infinite earth so does that
work differently
um
i don't know i know fox was airing
lucifer i don't know who the
who like actually produces it though
so um with dc
it's usually a little bit different
because usually everything ultimately
ties back to
warner media in some way um
all the various divisions still follow
fall under the warner brothers umbrella
so coordination is a little more
likely don't worry when the second act
ones
and second act one ends there's 20
minutes left in the film oh great
i need more water
way to put it
nice fresh sparkling water
[Music]
why are we re-re-re-reintroducing these
people
uh after watching this movie i caught my
eye on just to hear accompanying boys
and now they're so good in the world
ah the valley girl in zombieland 2 is
leia thompson's daughter oh
didn't know that i asked my friend if
jack sparrow really was the bad guy and
she said no he's just an alcoholic
fair
season two of hills has been announced
to premiere this december i know i'm
annoyed that it took that long i've been
waiting all year to find out when the
hell was gonna air
and it ends up being the end of the damn
year
i think lucifer is owned by netflix by
that point well no they were still only
airing it there's like there's a studio
producing it and there were networks
airing it they're not
the same that's what i'm saying netflix
is now
airing it but like i don't know who the
producing studio
is
why does the thing still have human eyes
because it's
unsettling oh god this friggin
thatch wig really
really i can get a better wig than that
online
for 40 bucks
oh jesus
i doubt that sparkling water well you
can't prove
it isn't
so reed's been on the run for a year
doing who the hell knows what
oh and now sue they're bringing sue in
to figure out because she can spot
patterns like how she broke down music
to patterns it's
almost like something a real movie would
do
calling back to something planted
earlier except it's stupid
oh cute it thinks it's a real movie
oh oh oh god
uh what are your thoughts on adam's
family as family values i like adam's
family a lot adam's family values has
good
aspects i don't like it as much
uh not that it's bad but i think it um
i think it recycled too many beats from
the first one uh especially around the
fact that you know the
threat ultimately came down to a woman
manipulating fester
i mean that was that was a bad call
so right now it's in spanish
and we have
miles tellers latino stunt double
the hell
[Laughter]
what
[Laughter]
he stretched his face to look like
somebody else's face
did he stretch himself a tan too
what the f oh my god ah
i worry that bill skarsgard will be
typecast now that his most well-known
role is
pennywise in it hey you know there's
another word for
for typecast it's called working
steadily for the rest of your life
there are worse problems to have
oh they must have saved money and
ordered the week from wish
it's about that level of quality
uh a draper over her head would have
been more convincing yep
lily bobby brown recently said she
nearly gave up acting after she didn't
get a role in game of thrones i'm
assuming it was lyanna mormont
she'd been good for that
sue can do a simple triangulation that's
what they needed her for yeah
because apparently as stupid as these
characters are everyone else
in the world is even dumber
let's all see alexander hamilton
together now
what's your name man alexander hamilton
cuts to reed and walter white both
living at a cabin in
new hampshire for that year with dexter
coming in after a hard day of
lumberjacking
that sounded dirty i'm sorry
uh is tomorrow's review doing part one
or both parts just part one
so now reed
i'll buy that reed has gotten a handle
on his powers but like he can take down
trained commandos
yeah sure
yep you couldn't put him in shorts
at least what
make a meme of that lavender reaction
for the memes
oh dear do you do setups
um like when i think too
it's usually about once a month
uh
have you ever seen the teddy bear
factory in shelburne
no i don't
think so
oh wait you mean the vermont teddy bear
factory yes
yes i have
back when i had a beard my gf called it
lumberjacking too
wait what are we talking about again
yeah
i used to have a beard but we broke up
oh that's an awful joke
adam sandler recently produced and
started a netflix original film called
halloween hubie
this movie makes a water boy look
dignified
look i suppose there's another thing i
deviate from especially for people my
age i never thought adam sandler was
funny
i didn't think uh billy madison was
funny i didn't think water boy was funny
i didn't think happy gilmore was funny
i never thought he was funny i remember
when
i was in middle school and
kids my age were like all about his his
uh his comedy album everyone's gonna
laugh at you
and one of them played it for me and i'm
just sitting there going
this is funny to you like even at that
age i've
never ever thought he was funny
also questions about you exercising
lately is the council geeks workout
video
a patreon exclusive uh no because of
my standard workout attire it's actually
on only fans
uh i'm gonna start teasing that the idea
that i have an only fans just to see if
people
start trying to look for it i i would
find that amusing
have you ever been to the ben jerry's
ice cream factory in waterbury that one
i actually haven't and i should because
you get free
samples but no i've actually never been
there
despite the fact that like at when um my
daughter's mother and i when we
when we got married
oh my god i don't even want to think
about how many years ago that happened
one of the gifts we gave to attendees at
like i think the
rehearsal dinner or something were
coupons to go to that factory
god miles shave that like
you're trying for five o'clock shut up
it's just this patchy he looks as bad as
i do
back when i used to try and have facial
hair ah
dude like laser that
[ __ ] off
is it concerning that i cuddle with a
stuffed dog toy at night
despite being 22 years old i have five
stuffed animals in my bed i am 38.
so i don't think it's bad
how would you fix fan four stick
that would be a project oh boy
turn on a freaking light yes i agree
rowan
i wholeheartedly agree so what now
they're
now they're going back why
why what what do they think they're
gonna get why
so many people hated sandler but in his
defense people wouldn't watch it if he
wasn't funny to someone
i mean i don't like it but he keeps
people working steadily in different
movies look from what i've heard he's a
lovely
guy in person and he obviously does
right by his friends he keeps his
friends working
um he said flat out that a lot of what
he does is
you know excuses to have vacations with
his friends at exotic locations and just
shoot a movie while they're there
there's nothing wrong with that but i'm
just saying that even
in his quote-unquote good days he never
appealed to me his humor never appealed
to me
do you have a pillow no i don't uh my
kid has a couple but i i that i don't
adam sandler is good when he does
serious stuff punch rock love funny
people and uncut gems oddly enough i've
yet to see any of those
what scene are you on uh okay so reed
just came back
and like fixed their equations i guess
in 10 minutes
it looks like franklin's about to go
talk to johnny
they're they're getting ready to go back
oh you know what i can give you a time
code
one hour 11 minutes 30 seconds that's
where i'm at
is halloween your favorite holiday i
don't know if i have a favorite holiday
i do like halloween though it's good
stuff
he's disappointed at the lack of only
fans see i say i don't actually have one
but here's the real question
do i in fact have it only fans
and i'm just trying to throw you off the
scent
all right franklin he's got a point
there that listening to you about how he
should shape up his life
is how he ended up in this place
now granted he still does something
stupidly reckless that you wouldn't have
uh approved of but like still you didn't
put him in this situation
uh i love it when you enter your live
streams with my cavity you should do it
for all your videos
it's a question of whether or not i
remember
uh sh su shu
zu should be the most pissed off at
having powers
she's got the coolest though like
honestly invisible woman has the coolest
powers with a lot of them
pulls on uh pulls up another chrome tab
and starts searching again
uh good luck to you my friend
the game's afoot how
how entertaining would that be like to
if i if i'm not saying i do
but if i actually had and only fans and
i like
dropped coded hints across
live streams and videos on how to find
it
landscapes changed yeah it's been a damn
year hey
how are you finding tick tock i was
surprised to see you on there your
videos are really good thank you
i have fun with it that's it's that i
mean that's
that's about it it's not something i'm
taking very seriously although i've
been way more successful at it than
things i have taken seriously
like twitter or or instagram
so who knows i bet trank had to be
talked down from doing full-on
hollow man invisibility effects well
they probably just slashed his budget
until he couldn't afford to do that
god how much longer is this movie i kind
of agree this fee
this feels like um a scene that should
have happened a half hour in
not an hour
holy crap
not possible yes we're all shocked about
the guy named von
doom somehow survived where did he get
the cape
from where'd he get where where did he
get a hood and cape
someone tell me
i bet trank had to be tucked oh you know
i read that off topic but
um terrifying big finished
recommendations that will only cost like
two dollars night thoughts
seven and eight with a hex story that
starts out creepy but really ramps up in
the second half
nice what is it only fans um
because i don't know your age cameron
i'm not gonna answer that
it is a thing for people over the age of
18.
that is what it is
youtube's most sensual scavenger hunt
it actually will be fun to see you lift
the weights in your videos while playing
sexy yet i know it in the background
now i'm old school i go for i'm too sexy
i'm too sexy for my shirt
saw a discussion over merchandise of
characters like rorschach some uh
argued that they know he's terrible but
just like the aesthetics reminds me of
jubilee
um like
there's value in that but like i i
i don't like the idea of it being
marketed at all because he's not someone
who should ever be looked up to
okay the second first act is complete
and they just realized there's 20
minutes left
and they need to wrap it up with a fight
yeah
like out of nowhere we now have a bad
guy
there hasn't been a bad guy in this
movie
for an hour and 15 minutes
and now there's a bad guy who we know
nothing about and has no motivation
toby pick
one accent
so is telekinetic why do they keep
giving
dr doom these freaking
weird super powers
why won't somebody just do him the way
that he's written he is one of the
greatest
super villains in comic books
let me guess head pop
yeah called it the only fan's idea
strikes me something a weird version of
the riddler would do
riddle me this batman
do you go to the gym no
no they couldn't even be bothered to
make his mouth articulate you know what
i'll let that pass because actual doctor
doom's mouth doesn't articulate
i'll let that one go
it doesn't help but like i'm not gonna
get hung up on it
now i'm just gonna walk down this
hallway and kill everybody
for no discernible reason whatsoever
why because the movie needs a villain
otherwise how will we know it's a climax
i can understand maybe having a poster
of watchmen or something but if you're
wearing a shirt with his quotes on it
then you might as well have
worn a red flag with armholes yeah
i bet this movie feels long enough to be
an extended laurie's movie without the
quality
so basically the hobbit oh
middle earth burn
fair though
wow this really is the gym of geeks
like this is about the extent of my
exercise normally
so now these four people
who have done almost nothing
coordinating with each other before
are going to work together and it's
going to have
no meaning whatsoever
because there's no theme to
there is no theme of team building in
this whole thing
uh actual dr doom is wearing a mask his
mouth underneath articulates
this is the actual doom face well yeah
but again
at this point whatever
it's a very pissed off crash test dummy
oh yeah oh my god you're right
ah they should have bulked him up a bit
ah
this cord keeps like drawing a center
line to my cleavage
in the words of bo burnham i don't go to
the gym because i'm self-conscious about
my body but i'm self-conscious about my
body because i don't go to the gym
yeah yeah
plus also you know i'm cheap
oh god look i i like that actor but that
was a terrible
terrible death face oh
oh that was awful
knowing what your favorite movie is
there's a line coming up that's going to
piss you off oh great
would you
would you rather a scary dentist or a
creepy doctor creepy doctor because i
feel like
i feel more vulnerable in a dentist's
chair than i do in a
doctor's office
very surprised by this no i guess not
i don't know franklin said i feel like
i'm supposed to care
oh no let's endanger the entire world
out of nowhere
because
the stakes i guess
and sky beam that's going to yes oh no
no it's the blue sky beam
it was ported over from avengers
but previously was on loan to suicide
squad
i think perry would disagree and i think
scary doctor is worse
sky portal cliche yeah
so this is probably the coolest thing
she's gonna do with her powers in the
whole movie is just create the
force ball
you've gotten much more hydrated i was
here an hour ago
hydration is important
oh big hero 6 a dozen other movies yeah
like i can't even
think of all the movies that have done
that
voted for the first time on sunday your
last live stream has inspired me to do
it i voted for biden
thank you
sincerely from the bottom of my heart
thank you
the matter from earth is being converted
to energy
because that's how physics works
what
is what i do clobbering time somebody
say it
i must have talked over the uh line that
was going to tick me off as a
ghostbusters fan
ordinary energy or pure energy right
oh look at that ben is useless
josh train clearly one clearly can't
write dialogue scenes and it's a dark
superhero movie so it can't have actions
on the end
because it's dark and that's what they
do
ghostbusters 2016 is another sky beam
oh that's right isn't it
physics physics physics
physics hope you're writing this down
right
exacto mundo which is a phrase i've
never said before and will now never say
again
oh no
no no
bad movie you go in the corner and
think about what you just did there is
no victor there's only
[Music]
doom
oh god damn it
what are your thoughts on psycho 1960
surprisingly holds up pretty well
largely on the back of anthony perkins
performance he's amazing
it's a shame he got typecast after that
said the person who kind of was like
typecasting isn't that bad earlier in
the same stream but like
you know is a good actor
ben is wet now he's completely useless
uh you got tenants mannerisms down
oh thank you ben
uh man
oh oh oh reese got determined face
he's gonna do a thing i bet
you know what i bet you he's gonna do a
science
watch out victor he's gonna do a science
on you
would you ever watch a horror movie in
the dark hall by yourself
sure
okay he's not even gonna do a science
he's gonna do a stretchy
oh god what the what the hell
is this
[Music]
everyone hulk said no banner only hulk
and thor ragnarok is a joke
yeah reed includes the master for the
intention
plan of hit it till it dies
oh so this this is your big let's work
together moment when teamwork has not
been
in any way thematic to this thing
up to this point oh
you do not get to pretend that this was
the point of the movie
oh
uh careful if you keep going uh
with the ten isms you'll start licking
things inappropriately telling people
you're so sorry and getting really whiny
upon threat of death
i'm sorry i am so sorry
uh re-reverse the polarity of anything
in this movie zero out of ten
uh why don't you wanna watch heather's
because i don't care i don't need to be
that flipping i don't want to be like
oh people shouldn't like the movie or
whatever like i just don't care
how much water will be needed for
ghostbusters 2 stream
he was smarter than you victor he didn't
put his hand in the green electric
goo yeah i
there it is
and it's not in any way cathartic
because it's what
i don't know why they thought saying
that that's what his brother said to
beat him up
would make it have meaning and make a
poignant it doesn't
makes it weird
i love that even all these years later
the solution for how to beat victor
seems to basically be a slightly
more uh over-the-top version of what
they did in the 2000s movie
which is hey let's all hit him at
once
why don't you like glee because they had
an episode called an
asian f about a character of asian
descent getting a b
that's why that show can
piss off
teller is thinking i wish jk simmons was
still throwing chairs in my head right
about now
not quite my tempo
uh they hit it and it died yay
science
oh what's worse ghostbusters 2016 or
ocean state i
liked ocean's eight shut your mouth
so you're feeling dark trying to stress
after this or
has this done too much damage look the
main thing that might be holding me back
from doing doctrines is distress is i
like i stream on my phone because i
can't stream from my
normal camera i can't hook it into the
computer
but the only thing that might hold me
back is getting that brought over here
and set up to
view the thing because that's like work
ah hey yay we did nothing
moral of the story uh
a portal and no glados
look at the massive crater where
thousands of people worked on that base
victory uh
you asked homer simpson to make a darn
fantastic four movie this be
hit
they basically just threatened the
government to get billions of dollars
yeah
that's a little
we work for you now what
they're in they're they're in their
freaking 20s at best
what the what
ah what
is this
have you ever been in a drunk coma
before no nor have i ever been blackout
drunk and i don't plan to try
there's no way he's going to say he's
actually going to say fantastic for the
movie takes itself too seriously
he's not going to actually say it
the the one nod to him being called the
thing
there's no post credit scenes by the way
oh okay
god his eyes are creepy
they set him up to say a fantastic four
and start the credits rolling opening
with the title
before he actually says it because the
film is embarrassed
by its own god damn
title
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh what the hell
oh
oh lord age of ultron ripoff
and it wasn't funny when age of ultron
did it either
for the record it's why it was good they
made up for it an endgame and actually
had him
say it
why is it that when lighthearted
properties are adapted why is it
a mature tone automatically means dark
and edgy i don't know
ben if you want some maturity brought to
a fantastic four without losing the
true heart of it you need to read mark
wade's run on it early 2000s it's
wonderful
hey look a movie that thought it was
getting a sequel
oh that's cute
there's another one for the joker laugh
cop is somebody actually collecting
these
i'm sure there's a compilation to be
made
have you ever been horseback riding
before yes
yes i have once
it's an odd experience to be riding on
top of something that you don't actually
have direct control over
it's actually a little bit unnerving if
i'm gonna be 100
honest with you it's not bad but it's
weird
okay i'm gonna
you know what i'm gonna stay on the
stream for a little bit
um while i
finish my water
when i'm old enough i'll join you with
plenty of water i've got a pool if that
helps
okay let me just
uh i can take these off i'd have those
oh squeezing my melon
my melons
i'm gonna get demonetized for that
oh lord mark wade's run isn't that the
one where
he undid dr doom's character to make him
more generically evil
not what i've read
he did something really awesome
with doom that
so okay um
so the background on doom on doctor doom
was that he has always had both elements
of dark magic
and technology but he's always favored
the technology he's much more about
building
the doom bots and these big machines and
whatever else and the
the magic was a like a background like
ace up his sleeve a little bit but it
wasn't something he
focused on as much in mark wade's run
he had doom say i made the wrong choice
i should have focused on dark magic
and i'm not going to get too much into
what he does to accomplish this
but he basically makes a pact with
demons
to acquire the level of
dark magic use that he would have had
if he'd spent the last however many
years he'd been trying to fight reed
with technology
studying magic instead and
it's scary and it's a really
great understanding of doom as a
character because a lot of people make
this argument that
doom has like this sense of nobility but
the thing is that's just something that
he
tells himself that he has doom is not
noble
not really he has he has an ego
and the things that he does in defense
of that ego will sometimes look like
nobility but they're not
really mark wade understood that he was
real it was good it was really good
you win 5 million on the lottery and
then aliens land and say they're going
to blow up the earth
what are you going to do with that money
well it depends how long before they
blow it up
because most things that would be fun to
do with five million dollars
would also need time and like does
anyone know that the aliens are gonna
blow the earth up or am i the only one
who's gonna know
because if everyone else knows a lot of
stuff that i might wanna do
ain't gonna happen because like ain't
nobody gotta be running
airlines or resorts or
what have you also vera has it only fan
is called the
not safe or worse section of the dicks
of the discord
okay see now nerdum you're outing me a
little bit
on that but yes
that is true there is a um
there is a not safer work channel on the
discord and the discord is a patreon
perk which does make it paywall which
makes it
adjacent to and only fans before you get
too worked up it's not
it's not that um
explicit but it's uh
it's more than i do on youtube
we're collecting these for use for your
psychological profile when the murders
start
your first crime scene will have dexter
finale written in blood
um close
it'll have this is scott buck's fault
written in some bodily fluid that may or
may not be blood
okay ew ew why did i say that eh
yes uh you'll be dismonetized but
demonetized from the melon jokes but not
the squaring oddly
yeah yeah
and i can tell you that just based off
the videos on the vera wild channel
like the one where i reviewed the um
the ucharmore breastplate that i was
sent
kept it completely clean that got
demonetized just because of the severity
of the cleavage
the one i did the same with the one i
did on the unclockable
tucking kit because i
[Music]
gave a before and after of my bulge in
that video
so that got demonetized too again zero
swearing
i can swear and not get demonetized
sexually suggestive content will get me
demonetized
way quicker i don't know why i'm kidding
this is like this creepy voice
hello clarice you wake up in the dark
and hear the screaming of the lambs
i don't know what i'm doing
i took my little cousin to see this for
her birthday in the theater i felt so
awful about it
isn't it don't you isn't that the worst
when like you you on faith
you take someone to a movie and like it
turns out terrible
i i um one of the one of the guys on the
fire and water
uh podcast network which is where i do
tough like a girl with my partner liz
um shag he was working in a movie
theater when
when batman returns came out
and he took all his co-workers to see it
he felt so bad he felt like the world's
biggest jerk
so what order would you put the four
films in what the fantastic four
movies okay um
i probably put the first one directed by
tim's story so like the one from 2000
first um then the roger corman
then rise of silver surfer and to be
clear rise to silver surfer isn't really
worse but i hold a grudge against it
because it did nothing to improve on
what the previous one did
despite a bunch of people giving a ton
of notes for ways they could have
improved it i gave a pass to the first
one i'm like
okay well you tried this but like
everyone's saying hey work on this stuff
so
and the sequel they worked on none of
that they ignored all feedback so that
one gets lower and then this bottom
absolute bottom
uh sorry i am a boy aren't i i don't
know
are you look uh
maybe that's something worth
putting on the record
i'm not sorry i was born male
like i'm not i
i feel like a more complete person for
the journey that i've gone through
and i needed the starting point i
started from to get
where i am now for that journey to have
any meaning if i
started somewhere closer to where i am
currently
then there wouldn't have been a journey
and to be slightly less philosophical
about it
i like my junk
i like that i got almost high minded
about it for uh for a hot second like
philosophical and then just
hey what penis
when they arrest you you'll be arguing
the blood is red water
[Laughter]
i thought singing would get you
demonetized um
so singing is weird what's what um
singing has done uh a couple of times to
the live streams
it's got me temporarily to monetize and
then i fought it
and like got it lifted but the thing is
if that happens
it loses the live stream playback
so like anyone watching the stream after
the fact
can't see the live stream um because
if they flag it for whatever reason that
goes away i don't know why
that makes no sense but it's a thing
uh follow the footsteps of firefly swear
in mandarin or cantonese and youtube
won't be able to tell
i have to learn mandarin or cantonese
are your thoughts on the silence of the
lambs and the shawshank redemption
uh they're both pretty good i mean
science of lambs has
not aged great in terms of some of the
things it does
with the character of buffalo bill and i
don't love the fact that a lot of people
when they think
of transgender people they think of
buffalo bill with his equipment
stowed going would you me
i me like i don't love that
that but you know that's not the film's
fault necessarily especially given the
time that it was made it's still a good
movie
i saw the film version of aragon with a
bunch of friends and we hated
it we just bitched about it on the way
home
uh i have a friend who
um we
we've gone to a couple of movies
together where we just
snark the whole way through she's
actually she's the friend i went and saw
last christmas with
and actually both chapters of hit and
snarked all the way through in every
case i did a study reading
jokes on edginess had to consider the
public
perception i'd be more fine with my kid
knowing about sex
than death but in our culture it's the
other way around yeah
it's very strange the way the u.s has
prioritized um
sexual content as being more
of an issue than violent content
um yeah it's it's weird
uh well at least listening to your
criticisms on a film is better
white noise than right for writing
scripts than how i met your mother
never got into that show
but is this movie topping from the
bottom
[Music]
can i be honest i love it when kink
terminology turns up in the live stream
it makes me very happy
i hated aragon so much when my dad
checked the dvd
out of the library i put it right in the
return pile by the front door that's how
much i hated the movie
i never read the book or saw the movie
uh
vera would have been a very different
journey yes that's true
transition is a long-term regeneration
uh yeah that makes sense
uh have you listened to the six musical
soundtrack
yes i have liz introduced me to that
i don't know how she came by but she uh
she let me in on that
[Music]
oh another great catch thank you
carowind for
dealing with these people so i don't
have two thoughts on stephen king
he's an author
right i like i've never actually read a
stephen king book
i tried a couple times i don't know i
didn't gel this style of writing have
you heard of manos hands of fate i'm
planning to show it to friends i've
heard of it
and no plans to watch it somebody wants
to pay me
have you ever been out of the country
before well yeah i'm
three hours away from the canadian
border for starters and i've also been
to england
uh isn't there a lie in silence where
they say buffalo bill was
ruled too mentally unstable to have
gender reassignment that's probably not
a good enough defense
no it's not a defense because the thing
is like yes there's a line
in signs of lambs uh hannibal electric's
exact
line is well actually there's two parts
to this
the first is that clarice starling has a
line
of but transsexuals are docile and
non-violent which first of all you're
classifying an entire group of people in
one way which is bs but
she says that and then uh hannibal
lecter says
um buffalo bill is not a true
transsexual but he strives to be
he believes he is and like so the
in dialogue the film tries to distance
itself from the idea that this is what
transsexuals are like
but the thing is at the end of the day
that's not people don't remember those
lines
they just remember buffalo bill with his
stuff
tucked between his legs going would you
me uh me
so you know i'm not gonna say the movie
didn't do anything to try and mitigate
that but that's not what sticks in the
head
at the end of the day i think it's
because stories in fiction need stakes
so there's more likely to be violence
and death whereas
it's easier to not have sexual
references
no i think it's all it's a societal
thing it's the
i mean it's america has a puritanical
mindset
baked into it in many ways that
takes a lot of time to shed
i wouldn't hate buffalo bills so much if
not for the part
of the insanity uh want being
trans and instead it was trans who was
just crazy
yeah i mean like it's it's weird and
complicated and like i'm
i i i don't want to say i could give a
pass to science little amazon unless
just meant to love it given when it was
written and when the movie was made
it's the kind of thing that like i'm not
gonna say it was okay
then but it's way less okay for anything
that's gonna do it now
it's kind of the thing
uh who's your favorite queen from six
i'd honestly i need to give it more
listens
i've only listened to it all the way
through twice i need to i need to give
some more goes
before i can make that call favorite
stephen king
film um stand by me
uh have you seen the goes wrong
show no i haven't even heard of that
it's a series of live plays where a
bunch of stuff intentionally goes wrong
like the sets being too small or actors
for getting their cues so funny
oh i had never even heard of that
thank you very much cal i appreciate
that
hey there just finding your stream i've
always thought transitioning was about
finding happiness regardless of others
like kinky boots have you seen it i have
seen
parts of kinky boots i haven't seen the
whole thing
um so i cannot i cannot speak to any
um particular message in that film
what transition is about
it honestly varies from person to person
um if you if you look um
at the videos i put out on the vera wild
channel uh wild cell why
lde all pretentious-like um
i've talked about my reasons
for the degree and manner
in which i've transitioned
but not everyone has the same reasons
because in my case i don't
i don't have one of the components that
is very common
amongst people who go through some
degree of transition and that is
dysphoria i don't really have it
so for me it would be accurate to say
that it's
about finding happiness because
i am happier now
with myself with who i
am with my sense of self with
my body than
i was before
but for other people it may not be about
finding happiness it may honestly be
about alleviating pain
uh particularly if they suffer from a
really acute dysphoria
it may be more about putting a stop to
the
pain of their body not matching their
sense of self
and maybe hopefully happiness will come
later but
the initial concern for a lot
of people who go through whatever degree
of transition they go through is to
make life hurt less
but for me speaking personally even
though i can't
speak to how well kinky boots delivers
that message for me it is more about
finding happiness
that is not a universal transitional
experience but it is
mine i have
slowly gradually and in a
very roundabout way been
finding myself
and the funny thing is
like i keep changing
so when i say i'm finding myself it's
not like oh i still have more to learn
no i think i know who i am right now
but who i am may yet change
further and
[Music]
i will continue along that
path wherever it goes because so far
following the path to be in tune with my
sense of self and be at peace with my
sense of self has only ever made my life
better
even when that goal post has shifted
further down whatever meandering bizarre
scenic route my life is taking
i've never felt the worse for following
and so i do and i will
what would you do for third row centered
seat tickets to hamilton
i don't know do you have them to offer
what are you asking me to do
have you seen batman the killing joke
animated movie thoughts on it
i have i have a review of
oh god from back when i was still trying
to make the green screen work
wow so it's old it's from back when the
movie first came out but you can find it
on the channel
and uh it it sucks
i it sucks dude
i actually even think less of it now
than i did when
i put the review out it's crap
like at the time
i think i said that like mark hamill
gave a good performance and he
did but like some of the line readings
were antithetical
to what was in the comic like a really
good example
there's i i forget what the preceding
lines to it are
but there's a point in the comic where
the joker
has this really f crest fallen look on
his
face speaking of this microphone he says
why aren't you laughing
and in the movie they instead had the
joker
punching batman going why aren't you
laughing and i'm like that no
i'm not necessarily going to blame mark
hamill because i'm pretty sure that's
what the script told them to do because
i know they scripted it as a fight
and that script sucks like i've heard
that brian azarello does
okay work elsewhere i've never liked
anything i've seen from the guy
i absolutely hated his work on wonder
woman and the new 52
and i hated what he did with the script
for the killing joke
so you know
i have nothing good to say about brian
azarello
so yeah it's definitely also societal i
also think that it's another reason
uh we got there i'm from the uk
i don't know if we're more or less
concerned about sex in the u.s i don't
know either
i i can't really compare
personally i think jane silent bob did
the talk while listening to stallions
and asking
would you me lol personally jay is
better than bill every day oh yeah
i haven't re-watched um
kevin smith movies in a while but i did
definitely like them for
for a time uh
i believe that if hannibal had been
allowed to do the events of silence
ellen page
was gonna play clarice and lee pace was
as james gum
that could have worked honestly i would
rather they didn't
because actually that that was one of my
complaints about that last
uh season of hannibal where it bled over
into the events of red dragon
was that i i knew too much of this story
and that bummed me out because like i
love the first and second season more
because
it feels more raw and unpredictable but
then when it started following the beats
of a story i already knew
it didn't lose me but it engaged me
slightly less
um let's see
i'm gonna try and catch up on these
questions and maybe call it a night
oh yeah yeah i'm out of water that's a
sign
that's it you can only choose one
beetlejuicer stand by me
why would you even compare those two
that's a weird
i'm the ghost with the most babe i i
still gotta go beetlejuice i re
i love like my love michael keane and
that so much
and he's in so little of it but he's so
good hey let me ask you a question is
this relationship really solid do i have
a shot at her at all
hey i may or may not have have used that
[Music]
line
uh my friend went on a bit of a rant at
me
rants i don't know anything about rams
why are you bringing that up
uh my friend might have been a rant at
me because i tend to always let
the villains win in my stuff saying they
should never win do you think he's right
no there are reasons to have the
villains win
my main thing would be
are you doing it just to have it be
darker because you can have a dark story
without having the villain win
um
so like if you like the villain winning
is not the expectation and you can
absolutely subvert
expectations but subverting expectations
should never be an end
in and of itself so my question for you
is
why do the villains always win and is it
the same reason every time
so that that might be something to think
about
uh what's worse fan four sticker suicide
squad oh
huh
a fan four sticks worse suicide squad is
slightly closer to being a movie
slightly only slightly but yeah
does transgender surgery hurt at all i
could tell you i've had no surgeries
and i also don't plan to have surgeries
the only surgery i've ever had in my
lifetime
was a vasectomy which was
not a transition surgery that was a i
have one kid i love my kid i don't want
more kids
surgery so and like
i mean they not they numb you up the
procedure doesn't hurt you just
you can't move much for the next few
days
which is uh which is then
you know laborious experience
but as far as like proper surgeries i
don't know
i've never had them i haven't had facial
feminization i haven't had
breast work done i haven't had bottom
surgery and i don't plan to have any of
them
tracheal shaves like this there's a ton
of stuff
i don't plan to have surgeries
like even if i reach a point where i am
like identifying as and living full-time
as a woman i still don't see
surgeries as part of my future
because
i look at my body and my face
i don't see a problem i don't see
anything that needs
correcting so i'm not someone to ask on
surgeries
and that's not to knock anyone who
has felt has made the decision to get
facial feminization or
breast augmentation or bottom surgery or
whatever i mean
honestly um i would maybe look at some
of the videos that jessie gender
did um from a couple of years ago after
well a couple years ago she had gender
reassignment surgery
and then more recently she had breast
augmentation done
and so she could answer those questions
she has live streams on occasion so she
would be someone to ask about that who
could answer
better than i could because haven't had
surgeries don't plan to
uh
inspired by real story well first of all
thank you again
cal much appreciated for the super chat
inspired by a real story drag queen
helps struggling factory owner from
losing it by making leather knee-high
boots for men
and accepting who they are i didn't
realize kiki boots was based off a true
story like i knew the basic plot of it
i didn't know that though oh that's nice
uh the whole movie just felt rushed have
you seen
h bomber guy's video on how it's
emblematic uh
the problem comics have had by trying to
be dark for the sake of it i have but i
don't remember a lot of the details of
that video
um at least not off the top of my head
did you know japan made x-men well hold
on
wolverine blade and iron man animes each
had one season i did i didn't know they
had full season i thought they were ovas
oh okay so that's news
rumor was that gary oldman went on
credit in the hannibal because he wanted
billing above hopkins and they said no
that's not
what i heard i heard he went uncredited
because he was
paranoid about um
being linked to the material like he
needed the work
actually gary oldman was having trouble
getting work at that particular point in
time
but he uh he didn't particularly care
for the material and didn't like having
his name
attached to it that was my understanding
i could be wrong
but that was my understanding on it um
because honestly like
what kind of revived his career was
being in the harry potter movies
uh harry potter and batman begins
in fairly rapid succession because
he'd gone through a while kind of after
um
fifth element of having a hard time
getting
work that he actually wanted to do
um would you see beetlejuice the
musical when it's on tour um maybe out
of morbid curiosity
i've seen a couple of clips i haven't
been super impressed
like in a weird way they actually slow
the character down to fit a musical
format because he's so rapid
fire in the movies uh movies i say
plural movie
um yeah it's it's a little bit weird to
see it
slow down and paste out for the sake of
a song
like no cut faster than that
oh wow
doctor in distress let's all answer his
sos
oh dear john like you and ben you're
like you're like
double teaming me and not in a way i
would like to be double-teamed
god i get like uh s stupidly
innuendo e when i'm hydrated
do you think uh
deep pdrn helps or hinders trans
acceptance
i'm not sure what that is
so you're gonna have to clarify that for
me because i'm not entirely sure what
that means
knives hurt i mean
that's that's what the people who have
strapped down to my
table have said but you know i i may
have but i may have said too much there
um are you
for trump or think he's the devil like
wavy david he's not the devil
he is a human being he is a
horrible horrible human being
who has been rewarded by our society
that values
perceived success in business over
humanity he's not the devil
he is a product of the society we live
in and we need to prepare to
own that a and b take a deep
hard look at what we
as a society have built that has allowed
someone like him
to be as successful as he is and to rise
to the office of the god
damn president
he's not the devil he's
our fault he is a human
creation and he is our responsibility
to get rid of
it varies from the protagonist never
getting a break to the point of them
winning
would seem like a cop out to the
protagonist being more villain-like
character
okay well it seems like you seem to be
plotting it out on a
case basis i would say just for variety
sake maybe try having the hero win once
in a while
just to you know subvert your friend's
expectations of how your other stories
always end
anyone else planning on a b for vendetta
watch on the 5th of november
too fitting this year ah remember
remember the 5th of november
i offered the role to christopher reeve
who obviously turned it down disgusted
oh oh the rolling hannibal oh god yeah
no i would expect him to turn that down
do you watch contra points content and
if not why
and should i cancel you
[Laughter]
uh yes i do
uh the story of kinky boots was a real
live event
in earl's barton in england the film and
stage production were inspired by the wj
brooks shoe company venture into fetish
footwear which is a good business
because
fetish footwear especially in sizes
large enough
for feet like mine you can charge
premium for that
what are your thoughts on knives out
it's brilliant i love it
uh and here i was talking about a movie
that's kinky you own by saying well you
had my attention
but now you have my erection
that is not what i said
but i might steal that line
uh but is biter better is biden better
or worse for america
biden is better than trump that's
enough
is biden what i want in a vacuum
objectively no he's not
i don't like him but he's better
than this
monster we've had
for four years we've had four years
of watching what he
does and seeing the damage and the human
toll of this walking [ __ ]
garbage pile of a human being
being in power and the people who will
cow down to him
i don't like biden but [ __ ]
anyone who implies that they are in any
way the same
biden is not enough
biden is not even a half measure he's a
quarter measure he is a milk toast
weak ass lame
ineffectual politician but that's better
than an
arsonist who is lighting the god
damn world on fire
will biden make the world better i don't
have a lot of faith that he will
but he won't actively make it
worse and it's a moral imperative
to stop the bleeding
even if you can't fix
the wound and cure the disease
right away you can at least stop
the bleeding
that's how two live streams in a row i
think where i've gone off on one
on political issues
oh i'm sorry
and cal i hope you don't think that i
was mad at you
for asking that question because i i
don't think
and i didn't get the impression that you
were trying to stir
stuff up by asking me that but it is a
question that infuriates me
biden a vote for biden is a vote for an
old status quo that frankly wasn't good
enough
but that old status quo was still better
than the hell hole that we are being
dragged down into over the past four
years
that's the reality
and is it is at this point a moral
imperative
to vote whatever will remove trump from
office and votes for a third party won't
do that
a vote for biden will
you don't have to like biden if you
acknowledge that trump is a cancer on
this country
then it is a moral imperative to remove
him
and voting for biden will do that we can
deal with the fact that
biden isn't good enough later
that is a more manageable problem than
trump is
because biden isn't good enough
but he's better than this
and that's a start
any improvement any journey starts with
one step
or at the very least at the minimum
begins with stopping walking
in the direction that is harming
everything and maybe
maybe voting for biden and getting him
in won't even truly be a step in the
right direction but at least it will
stop
the progress down the path that we are
going which is a path of destruction
and hate and death
that's not something i normally say i
really try not to be over hyperbolic
about this but people are
dying because of
trump people are dead people
are dying and more people will die
would you rather listen likes war master
series or missy probably war master i
thought it was
i love that i've just transitioned
seamlessly back into the chat oh
i i thought warmaster was a little
deeper than missy though missy was more
fun but like i want to see the depths
that they go with the
with the warm master um
i'm gonna lay off my water now that
might be wise ben no i'm i'm done
i'm gonna try and catch up on the
questions and call out tonight do you
have any tattoos no
zero i'd always strike uh people as a
sort of person who would have tattoos
but nope i got nothing
no piercings other than the ears too
which i don't even have earrings in
right now i had to take him out because
i had the headphones on
uh from the two scenes i've seen a brad
pitt so far in 12 monkeys i don't stupid
the academy he
saw in his performance surprised to see
frank gorshin in it i
actually liked brad pitt in that one
personally i thought i thought he was
fun
anyone who is capable of getting
themselves made president
no i can't be allowed to to do the job
douglas adams
uh yeah yeah
i think douglas adams might have been on
to something with that one
uh oh i know large feet i usually fit in
size 13 wide or 14
and sorry for pissing you off but i'm
glad to meet someone who is for biden
but can't admit he's a [ __ ] candidate
thank you
you're welcome
couldn't agree more in heart the passion
thank you tracy thank you very much
oh oh geez pano i'm sorry i'm sorry if i
if i if i've scared you off now
it doesn't usually get this intense but
like look
we're two weeks away from an election
that
is high stakes and heated
this is not my norm but like this is
where i'm at right now uh i'm sorry
well no i'm not sorry i'm not
but it's just the reality right now i
can only imagine what the stream is
going to be like on election night i'm
really
worried for you guys can we go back to
the doctor in distress spit roasting
ugh
i the things i could say about the term
spit roasting
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep them to myself
um
see here's the thing i'm i'm gonna do on
election night same thing i did
uh last time which is i am not gonna sit
up all night watching
i think especially this year because so
many votes are being done
mail and we are not realistically going
to have
um a result on the night
not really it's gonna take a few days or
even a week
and trump's gonna fight it every friggin
step of the way i need to move off this
topic
uh you discuss your opinion uh which
most people
who might meet and ask about
where they stand not for being a troll
but ask questions
and seeing if i get discussion or ban
sign of intellect
thanks cow i'm i'm glad i i didn't
disappoint
you yes i should i should wrap this up
hey for no other reason then like i'm
i'm out of water i should stop uh did
you enjoy queers folk us
favorite character and why i've never
seen it
my partner liz has i never have i've
never seen either version
i'm a bad queer uh
cause of the new restrictions i'm
sticking with making audio dramas
because filming is going to be a
nightmare on the plus side
i can put the characters in more dire
situations this is true
like there is advantage to audio as a
medium
it's okay i understand thank you pano i
appreciate that
uh so the word queer is banned funny
that
um that actually might be my fault
because i have it um i have it flagged
as as a word that marks any comment that
uses it as
um flagged for review
not automatically blocked but like i get
to review it
first i might have to take that one off
the list of words that trigger
a flag for review because i mean
queer is a term i use to describe myself
i might need to take that one off the
list
are you a ballet dancer
uh i i am i am not a trained dancer in
any form of dance whatsoever
uh daily reminder to watch infinity
train thank
you willow i i do i do have it
like earmarked on hbo max
so that's that's a step going that like
i've only just started watching avatar
for crying out loud like i do
i do have to let me finish some other
stuff first
aidan gillen is one of the leads in the
uk version
i did know that i knew that because of a
joke that
yahtzee made on um zero punctuation
once which is a weird reason to know
something
the only downside is i have all the
character development and backstory and
live action
because that's got more of a narrative
while the audios or stand alone oh
that that may take some juggling
i'm so glad you and jesse got to the
scorpius episodes brilliant character i
love harvey too
oh don't tell jesse about harvey
i'm so excited to get to harvey in the
next season
on farscape oh oh i love harvey so much
he's
great we're talking about firescape if
people didn't know
oh
thank you for another enjoyable live
stream you're welcome rowan what are
your thoughts on avatar
2009 what do you mean the james cameron
movie
it's good like it's become fashionable
to crap all over it but no
it's good it's not great it's not
amazing but it was an experience it was
one i definitely glad i had
i don't know who the hell is bankrolling
his multiple sequels or why they think
those will work but whatever
in distress now i'm doing oh for god's
sake go up to like three people now
uh could be
to be fear to be fear to be fair
most of my cultural reference points
cover room zero punctuation
uh never asked what type of water were
you drinking
um the kind that i just knocked over the
empty bottle for
uh riesling water
okay okay i gotta stop i'm caught up on
questions
i gotta stop this has been going on for
two hours
whoa
done two and a half finished
oh god now more questions do you watch
mystery science theater 3000
um occasionally i'm not current on just
google image
harvey yes i never probably watched
farscape oh man
it's no longer double meaning now it's
nope not gonna say it
okay thank you everybody thank you for
tuning in
thank you for being here um this
is this has been uh this has been a
thing i watched about
what an hour and a half movie and then
ranted for another hour after that
i hope you are oh god dang
do you agree gay characters uh don't
need spotlight uh
but can be done like the legend of
course ending episode i haven't seen
legend of korra yet so i can't answer
that really
um but in it okay i'm putting my hand up
here so i don't see the chat anymore and
i don't see that questions are being
directed to me anymore and i actually
end
this dang stream thank you very much for
tuning in
stay safe be well stay
hydrated be kind and please remember
that you are beautiful you are valid
you are loved
you are the council and i only run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
my kennedy